welcome to the dean shaw media host
and trending in the news is the topic of
afghanistan all eyes are on afghanistan
so we got
angelina jolie talking about afghanistan
just opening up her instagram account
for the first time because she got a
letter from
a young girl from afghanistan we got
benny shapiro talking about afghanistan
say that women have rights that comply
with sharia that means women don't have
rights uh within the frameworks of islam
under sharia law uh-huh
there's a lot that could be said on a
lot of the things that people are
talking about so to cross-check some of
these things and separate fact from
fiction because in there you're gonna
have islam and these terms that you're
probably not familiar with being brought
up so we want to go ahead and educate
you we're not siding with any political
party we just want to get to the truth a
lot of these matters so let's go ahead
and bring our next guest out
dr sabil ahmed here on the dean show the
dean
assalam alaikum peace be with you
eddie
peace be upon you too how are you doing
alhamdulillah all praise be to allah you
see a lot of alhamdulillah
you see a lot of people coming out of
the woodwork now it's interesting you
had angelina jolie and i don't know if
this was a
good opportunity for her now because she
didn't have an instagram account and now
under the pretext of helping the afghan
women she's decided to launch her
instagram account and come out because
someone wrote her a letter
and she's coming out to help the women
of afghanistan which seems like a very
noble and righteous thing what do you
think about that
well first and foremost as you mentioned
we are not here to support a people the
taliban afghanistan or any government
any any you know people we are here to
dissect the truth
we want to find out there are so many
things going on from all over the world
we want to find out the truth from the
friction and what does islam teach in
all of these chaotic things times that
we are going through so when it comes to
angelina jolie
you know anytime anyone wants to help
out the people who are helpless we have
to say that's a good deed
however we have to right away we have to
you know ask her a question
that yes if you're helping out if you're
if you want to be the voice of the
people the girls in in afghanistan what
about the voice of the girls in this
country in the u.s what about the women
who are going through so much suffering
in this country
where is your voice for those
individuals
and then you may be asking you know
brother sabil what voice of what people
people are free over here in this
country there is no suffering right a
person may be thinking and saying that
so what i would say to them is i would
say that uh you know what about the
voice of those uh women 93 000 of them
each single year in the usa they are
raped
in this country by americans on on the
american women who is going to speak up
who is going to be their voice
they are 20 of the ladies in this
country they they go through incest
by their family members by their friends
anyone who is going to be their their
voice
there are 7.8 million spousal abuse
cases in this country who is going to be
their voice
right and the list goes on and on all of
this me to movement
so we have to be the voice of every
person suffering anywhere in the world
may that be here
may that be france may that be
afghanistan or anywhere around the world
and that's what islam teaches us
i want to get the audience involved in
the comment section below
i want you this is pretty
straightforward and easy if you guys can
go ahead and do some research and put
those numbers in the comments to what uh
dr bill had mentioned some of these uh
facts
and it seems like you're pointing out
some hypocrisy here hypocrisy double
standard i mean we have to be the voice
of every person who who
who does not have a voice but why are we
just picking and choosing
only the muslim ladies or only the
muslim girls because that gives the
impression that only muslim ladies are
suffering
by the muslims no we have to let people
know that this is a human problem and it
is prevalent unfortunately in every
country in the world
so we as humans we as americans and yes
that's what islam teaches us as muslims
we have to take care
of every person poor the needy the
hopeless and the homeless anywhere
around the world okay so it seems like
okay if there's a legitimate issue here
that we want to go ahead and address
we're going to dress as a community as a
global human community right
but hold on don't forget about like
other where is the right at this time
where you have women being oppressed for
instance in france
and now they want to go to school but
they can't go to school just because now
they're wearing the hijab they're
imitating mary the mother of jesus who
muslims by the way love and revere
him and his blessed mother jesus is one
of the greatest messengers said to
mankind muslims love him and the muslim
women they're obeying the commands of
god almighty and now they're trying to
dress in this modest way of dress and
now france marcon whoever the president
over there and others there's
oppressing the women they're not letting
them go to school
why
angelina jolie this is your chance to
shine
and help the muslim women of france
would you agree exactly you know i
received a post actually and in that
post it says uh you can display it later
women cannot go to school or study if
they go against what they are ordered to
wear and will end up getting arrested
then it says which country do you think
that is
people all over the world they may say
it's afghanistan the taliban no that's
france
so where is the freedom of choice of the
muslim ladies in france you know they
cannot go outside freedom to what what
they want to wear
so it's important as i said islam is a
just faith islam takes all humans as
equal and we want to stand up for rights
human rights you know women's rights uh
equality of all the humans so we have to
be fair we have to be just and that's a
good message for uh angelina jolie and
all the people of conscience so what
action items again action items now
we're giving to the d show audience
viewers in the comments i want you to
add some of these numbers
the amount of incest
you know the destruction of society with
the porn industry i mean it's just
rampant i mean homes are being destroyed
the little minds are being taken away
you know
you have also
sex
slavery prostitution prostitution and
you have sex slavery happening here in
our
in in this country that we love this is
something that look this up this is
something the pedophile ring is just you
know through the roof you have so many
kids being molested
pedophile pedophilia is just rampant
and i mean when you hear this like in
america that there is sex slavery
happening today i mean it's an industry
that's growing why isn't it being talked
about this is an action item for you
guys just look at the statistics look at
this and put in the comments below but
let's give her angelina jolie some
action items that she can actually so
she can keep it fair and balanced yeah
so brother eddie just imagine
these statistics that i mentioned
if they were done by the people by some
muslims by the taliban the world would
be in a pro there would be wall-to-wall
coverage in the media just imagine if
taliban were raping 93 000 muslim women
in that country
what do you think will happen there
would be invasion after invasion you
know the poor ladies up there
they're getting raped no we have to
stand up for any person who is getting
you know who's getting victimized so we
have to clean up our own country we love
this country and you know god wants us
to be fair and just
and help any person anywhere in the
world
you also have we'll switch for a moment
to a conservative voice that's out there
he's also of jewish descent
and let's touch upon this uh benny
shapiro
he's got a pretty big following and he's
also creating some hysteria here because
he's using the term sharia say that
women have rights that comply with
sharia that means women don't have
rights
he's using the terms islam uh within the
frameworks of islam under sharia
and he's sending off a message kind of
like okay
now
if anything has to do with shadier islam
that now you know catastrophe's about to
hit and he's using some really
inflammatory language
uh out there what what do you have to
say to some of these things that uh
benny's saying
you know it's really important
we have to be really cautious uh when
anyone brings you any news the quran
says in chapter 49 surah hujarat verse
number 6
that if any disbeliever brings you a
news investigate so you don't harm
people out of ignorance and you don't
regret it later on
so if someone is saying you know what
sharia says this
jihad means that that part of that
that country that those people are doing
that we have to take it with a grain of
salt we have to investigate first and
foremost so when we investigate uh
sharia for example
sharia literally it means you know the
guidance that our creator has given for
humanity so we can live
with peace with the creator peace with
other humans
and live in justice and equality and and
unity within all of humanity so that's
what sharia means
sharia is not about oppressing women or
taking you know
uh oppressing uh the people who are
non-believers
sharia gives rights
equal rights uh to the women
so if someone is saying you know what
sharia we have to blame uh we have to
blame the taliban because they want to
implement the sharia
first and foremost taliban are no angels
they're not perfect if they're doing
anything wrong and they are obviously we
have to blame them and not islam not
sharia and definitely not the quran
so sharia actually the viewers may be
surprised to find out sharia gave
humongous rights to women
you know the oldest continuous
university in the whole world according
to unesco
it was made by a muslim lady
who was empowered by the sharia sharia
gives muslim ladies
not to be
forced into marriage
that's a surprise for ben shapiro i
guess sharia give muslim ladies uh that
they can initiate a divorce if they if
they want to
they can have their own property um so
all of these humongous rights were given
by the sharia if some country is not
implementing it
we have to blame them and not the
perfect sharia that allah god has given
to us
a couple of points i want to mention
to
benny shapiro i had rabbi shapiro on the
dean's show oh really and he was talking
about we were talking about touching
upon the jewish sharia
that you many people don't know you have
also christian sharia yes you have also
mentioned in the bible
because many people don't know like
christians and jews who are arabic
speaking they
don't refer to
god as god they've referred to god as
allah
and they have the term also sharia you
have shadia mentioned 200 plus times
in the yeah in the in the uh
christian jewish
bible
and this is confirmed you can check i
like i said i had rabbi shapiro and we
touched upon this
so you had moses
who was and this is great because these
are educational moments we hear these
things and people speaking un
academically and they just you know
going off their whims and their
fantasies and desires a lot of people
have this just hate inside their hearts
and they're protected we don't know
what's in their hearts but you can just
guess they're just angry uneducated and
now they're using such inflammatory
language and words just to like rile
people up maybe get their numbers up
whoever the case and it's big business
bashing islam so again like you said
we're not supporting any political party
or group but as soon as you bring in
islamic terms and islam now hold on
let's let's let's fact check you
so
these are the things that we mentioned
um that they don't know sharia it's in
the bible 200 plus times moses moses
brought shadia yes if you if you look at
the tenth commandment
if you look into the old testament the
book of exodus chapter 20 verse number
three the ten commandments are the
sharia guidance that prophet moses peace
be upon him right a mighty prophet that
he brought from god to the people so we
said that is the guidance which is a
humongously beneficial guidance you know
worship only one god do not make any
graven images
be good to your parents do not lie do
not cheat do not murder all of these are
sharia guidance we say that were given
by god to prophet moses and his people
so yes sharia is there in the old
testament and sharia guidance is there
in the new testament
and then the last prophet of god
muhammad peace be upon him he was given
the complete guidance a complete sharia
using that humanity can prosper get
united be moral be just and peace would
be there between humanity definitely
between humanity and the creator yeah we
want to give credit where credit is due
like for instance angelina jolie yeah
she was at one point i believe she was
speaking out and creating awareness for
the greatest genocide that happened
after world war ii in bosnia you had
rape camps set up there and you had the
chutneys and these were people their
priests were blessing their guns
you know and they were doing this on
behalf of christianity that's what they
thought but we know that this had
nothing to do with jesus as christianity
but they are christian and the chutneys
and they were doing some uh really
horrific evil things
in so where many people don't know you
can look this up and this is a whole
different topic but when people are
doing good we're going to commend that
good of course so this is very important
now she's coming out hopefully she has a
good intention she's trying to do some
good we invite her to come on to the
dean's show and she could talk about
this and even uh benny shapiro we bring
him on and let's have a conversation
it's very important to have these
conversations to fact check things so
people don't walk away thinking like
okay sharia you know boogeyman coming to
get me islam backwards oppresses women
you know
you know a human being and we could
touch upon this a human being will make
uh grave errors make mistakes
they might end up or a group of human
beings might end up oppressing
a
society of people but islam can never be
oppressive
it could never be that's the example of
prophet muhammad peace be upon him
that's the example coming from the quran
you know one example that we can give to
ben shapiro for example
that there is a synagogue in afghanistan
that has been there for literally
centuries when taliban came to power
they actually protected it they gave the
jews and afghanistan a right
to openly go and pray in there right so
the jews have the
they have the autonomy to have their own
culture their own synagogue their own
freedoms and that was the example coming
from also prophet muhammad peace be upon
him
when he went from makkah to madina in
the very first migration he found a
a big number of jews up there
so what he did was he made a
constitution with them called as the
madinah charter and in the charter it
says that the jews and the muslims would
be one people we are going to look out
for each other and the jews you have
your own synagogues your own culture
your own freedoms your own punishment
system your own justice system so there
was a so they were a autonomous jewish
state within the true islamic state so
that is uh
the gold standard that that we need to
follow that's the the big question what
is your measuring stick in life your
morality measuring stick what's your
moral compass
we had for instance khabib who's now
like somebody who many people know of he
was the ufc fighter and he got some heat
because he made a statement about these
ring girls
you know the ring girls he said this is
like they're pretty much useless the job
is useless you follow me not saying the
women themselves you know islam honors
the woman honors their our you know
aunts our mothers you know heaven as
prophet muhammad said is under the feet
of your mother so this is something that
you can end up going to the hellfire if
in today's society where you have young
kids throwing f-bombs at their mothers
at their parents you know throwing them
in throwing them into uh nursing homes
at the first chance they get
uh so
and forgetting about them right so the
grave respect towards our elders
it's kind of normal in the society right
exposing women as sex objects it's
rampant here you know this is abuse at a
high at a really high level
so where are you now to go ahead
and correct these wrongs that are
happening you follow me and but here's
the thing that's when the moral compass
is on what are you judging by it's kind
of you think okay the less i wear the
more i'm free
you know um i have said this many times
yes we have to call out any abuse
of any rights anywhere in the world
but u.s is in no position to call out
you know
racism in some other country human
rights in some other country women's
rights in some other country when we
know that right in our country
all of these abuses you know just last
year all of these racial rights that we
saw
just imagine if the same thing would
have happened in afghanistan
media would be like a bigger pro the
whole world would be in a in a bigger
pro wall-to-wall coverage look at these
muslims you know no justice you know
look at how they're oppressing
the
blacks and the people of color
so we have to be uh fair we cannot be
hypocrites we cannot have double
standard islam wants us to be fair and
just yeah here's one other angelina
jolie felt compelled to join in a
movement when women and young people in
afghanistan are losing the ability to
communicate on social media and express
themselves freely so they were talking
about freedom of choice i mean this is i
you know with all due respect we have
not seen more
people losing their ability
of freedom of speech now here like we're
experiencing here in the us
and now to go ahead and to make those
comments again without mentioning the
things that are going on here you know i
have so many people who will talk about
certain topics and they're getting their
youtube channels their facebook channels
everything is just being
taken down people are losing them so
what happened to freedom of speech here
that people are losing
and now we're going to criticize someone
in another country what about our home
right here yeah yeah you know they
i know a few muslim scholars when they
made some statements about lgbt then why
are you talking about the alphabet
movement
yes okay so lgbt movement right the
homosexuality the lesbian all of that uh
they have been banned from traveling to
this country
so where is the freedom for those
individuals to freely you know talk
their mind and to have a discussion and
you know and the fair comments regarding
that topic yeah
so it's important yeah yeah that's
that's one i mean people have talked
about you know other topics and they
know they cannot say certain words
because
they will get their videos taken down
you know so again this is just for
angelina jolie and many others i mean
this is we to keep it all across the
board
where it's fair and balanced
so one topic you know some people some
viewers they may have in mind when they
see the photos and also the images
coming from there is you know this uh
enforcement of the hijab or the modest
covering
no one has the right to enforce people
may say right women have women have the
right whatever they wear
but that's not the case anywhere in the
world anytime in history
as all of us we know
that uh
unrestricted freedoms for any individual
never happen in the history of humanity
i mean a society cannot be civilized
with unrestricted freedoms there have to
be some restrictions to the freedoms yes
freedom should be there we are all for
freedoms islam is there for freedoms you
know in fact the quran says in chapter 2
verse number 256
that that there is no compulsion in
faith people have a freedom to choose
their faith however it's important in
our country there is restriction to what
we can wear what we cannot wear if we
disobey those restrictions there would
be arrests there would be fines you know
when you go to the airplane people have
always been you know uh
taken out from the airplanes
because they were not wearing something
proper when people go to schools and
colleges they are always a dress code
uh when we go to a restaurant there is a
dress code
so right now there is a dress code for
the map for the mask
many places you have to wear the mask
which is a mandatory
so taliban and afghanistan if they are
enforcing certain laws of modesty
they they're not going against anything
that all of us all over the world that
we are doing it likewise anyway
we may disagree with the methodology
that they are using maybe the aggressive
methodology but the principle
the concept of modesty is there in any
country in the bible it is their old
testament in the new testament is it is
there in the first book of corinthians
chapter 11 verse number five and six
the the christian ladies they are
commanded to also cover their hair it's
a commandment
right
so when our creator has given a dress
code for both males and females we have
to cover certain parts of the body we
cannot wear tight clothes we cannot wear
transparent clothes we cannot get close
of the opposite gender so these are the
commandments
that maintains the chastity and the
harmony and the justice and peace in the
society
so we may disagree with the way that
they are implementing it but we cannot
disagree with the concept of modesty
yeah just to touch upon that yeah you
have
certain medical interventions that are
happening now
and against
people's
consent
uh and many people are being forced into
a corner and they might not agree with
things but this is how
now um
it's being pushed on a certain pretext
and you don't really at the end of the
day you're losing more and more of your
freedom so that's interesting it's how
you make that example over here you also
now in another country the whole point
is we have enough problems here why are
we
why are we you know if we took the
majority of that money
and spent it here you have people that
like chicago you know you you know they
called chicago chirac
oh really yeah you heard that term yeah
yeah because it's so much violence and
shootings and whatnot you have uh places
like detroit
um and other places that imagine if we
took that money and we opened up youth
centers we made more park we
increased the level for education
imagine if that money was taken invested
in some of these urban areas and other
places around the cities imagine you
know how much more in healthcare and all
imagine how much more good can be done
two trillion dollars
my tax paying dollars and your tax
paying dollars and their tax paying
dollars that we have spent up there
in afghanistan right you know there is a
literally thousands if not millions of
people in this country who are in the
student depth
they cannot purchase cars they cannot
purchase homes they are in a vicious
cycle we could have used that money
right over here for the education of our
youth our children and and our families
in all of this wastage close to like 10
trillion dollars
in the war in afghanistan in different
places so there's precious money that we
should be using over here how many
single mother homes how many homes
that are people don't have homes they're
living in cardboard boxes just look at
la you look at you know chicago look at
these major cities where people are
homeless
right imagine how many people we can
give homes take care of how many people
give jobs so they can have homes how
many people that money can go ahead and
be spent wisely properly if put back
here
yeah you know uh it's not just the money
part it's the loss of lives loss of
suffering that's a whole different uh no
but we have to touch upon it you know uh
more than one million people
people say three million four million
five million just in iraq
of the embargo and the drone missiles
and the occupation and this you know
mega bombs
same thing one million people innocent
people
in afghanistan
they had to suffer our people in in this
country has to suffer right more than 5
000 families their youth they died the
soldiers over here what about all of
them
so it's important for us that yes
if we see that there are problems in
other country yes let's work with them
to solve the problems and that's what
islam teaches we have problems enough
problems in this country enough problems
in france uh you know
australia
south america so invasion is not a
solution
invasion is not a solution right war is
not a solution war should be the last
resort we have to exhaust all the means
but we can prevent many many sufferings
first we have to take care of our
country
many have said war is a racket and you
go into other countries and you plunder
and you steal and what happens is now
it becomes a business and it's sad to
say it and i and the other p at the
innocent afghan people's expense so you
mentioned something about the 51st state
yeah yeah you know it's really important
some of us may be surprised to find out
that you know how come you us is pulling
out of afghanistan
we may you know for us americans we
think that you know afghanistan is part
of the u.s it's not the 51st state of
the u.s no
we were uninvited guests in afghanistan
you know afghanistan is uh what they
call it it's called as the graveyard of
the empires
the mongols came
to rule afghanistan they were defeated
right
the mughals came to rule afghanistan
they were defeated
the british three times in history they
wanted to rule afghanistan they were
kicked out
russia recently and u.s right now
so
you know it's important that uh
ruling and all of that but you know one
important topic by the eddie
is the opium trade
[Music]
all of us we know drug problem is a
problem unfortunately that is plaguing
many parts of the world especially the
western countries
afghanistan before the taliban came to
power in 1996 they used to have like 95
percent of the opium trade
it was from afghanistan before before
the taliban came to power after the
taliban came to power in 1996 all the
way to 2001 they eradicated the opium
problem
and the narcotic problem
so one of the statements that
they made when they came to power now is
that we want to make afghanistan
narcotic free
that's a good thing right that's a good
thing
but after they were kicked out by our
forces in 2001 again the opm trade
thanks to the blessings of the us it
went up again 95 percent
that's destroying humanity of our youth
our children
i'm not saying that you know
that they're angels no we they are just
like us uh they are making mistake we
have to support them we have to educate
them this is what islam says
but we have to look at the realities opm
trade and the narcotics and the drug
problem at least they want to solve it
we don't have a solution over here
i mean you got all your
your pipes you know leaking in your
house
and your house is flooding
and now you're over here um going to
someone else's house to try to you know
patch up there plumbing i mean take care
of you know
we we have so many issues happening and
i i see what you said i mean it's just
now going you had drone attacks
you know captaining over there you've
had innocent people
dying innocent children and it's just
interesting where were you like for 20
years someone like
angelina jolie
and you had a guest on the other day who
was talking about that money
that wasn't spent in afghanistan that
went into people's actually came back
here he was talking about how coca-cola
bottles and others they were priced up
to like almost like 30 40 bucks for for
us a can of coke so it was just being
brought back here there was no roads no
schools there was there's nothing
built there yeah and and the only
winners i would say
it's not the fun people it's not the you
know american people it is the war
machines all of these big corporations
all of these you know uh
all of these production plans all of
these uh you know big ceos they were
making money out of these wars
so we have to realize that it is coming
from my and your tax paying dollars
have you heard the name of uh
sister yvonne ridley yeah yeah i just
had her head around the program yes yes
yes so interesting right
we can demonize taliban and afghanistan
all we want yes they're not perfect
we're not here to support them
yvonne ridley way back about 20 or so
years ago
she was captured she she was a ua uk
journalist she went to afghanistan for
reporting and she got captured by the
taliban
and she was there for a few months or so
and she became really afraid and she she
was abusing them and spitting at them
with a smile the taliban told her you
know why are you behaving like this with
us uh you are our guest we want to take
make the best treatment of you she was
given a royal treatment and she was
freed she went back to uk
england and there of her own choice she
embraced the faith of islam because of
the behavior of the taliban
so what we can what can we conclude from
this one major thing is
the ayah in the verbatim word of god
almighty the quran when the news comes
to you
from a fascic from an evildoer from
a person like this you need to really
do your research go and check it up you
cannot just blindly follow so let's talk
about that and what lessons we can take
from all this you mentioned also because
that's the buzz now you know
it's about uh women
and like the whole world's
worried about these women i mean
so
uh what what do you say to this you had
also a reporter an executive others on
the ground so you have other news coming
out that's no no our our channel's still
up we're still good you know so it's
like seeing through the media
manipulation the lies the distortion and
the agenda that many people push through
naive minds if you're naive if you don't
really have some fact checking done then
you're going to end up falling for a lot
of the misinformation yeah so one
important action item for all of us is
chapter 49 of the quran verse number 6
that encourages and commands every
single one of us the believers to
investigate the news
and we should know that things are
really fluid up there
we cannot make any conclusions when the
things are fluid
and we have to take everything with a
grain of salt because you know obviously
uh the us
we lost the war okay this is just
granted four presidents right uh
involved in this war two trillion
dollars uh
uh you know all of this suffering
20 years we lost the war we have to just
take it take it right it's a hard pill
to solve for some people
however
losers demonize the winners
this is just a fact of war people
demonize each other in the war so we
have to take the news with a grain of
salt coming from both sides i'm not just
saying from the us coming from both
sides so we have to watch neutral news
al jazeera for example or bbc for
example so we have to uh expand our
scope of the news media the news
channels and the social media
number two is important
that uh we when we look into the
realities of the ground we also have to
find out that
what are the women in afghanistan what
are they saying what are they doing so
npr they did a report
in which they
they had a live interview
with a journalist up there
and that journalist they were asked the
question what do you see on the street
are the women up there what are they
doing do you see them
and he reported back to npr saying that
you know what they're women they're
roaming around there is a coffee shop i
can see women there that are socializing
up there
and then when you see this news anchor
you know there is this lady
of one news
executive says we thought we would be
shut down by now
so this lady a muslim lady she's an
anchor person right she's an anchor
person and she's saying that you know
i'm their
life every day
having the news and taliban has not shut
me down and she's not the only person
there are many many ladies like that
they're not perfect but we have to know
that there is more to what our media is
saying so we as humans an action item is
investigate more look into the other
channels other you know non-american
channels i would say
uh talk to muslims talk to muslim
scholars
but the most important thing is do not
judge islam but the actions of some
people out there
right islam is perfect sharia is perfect
the quran is perfect the noble example
of muhammad peace be upon him is perfect
so do not judge
that which is perfect by the actions on
the ground of those individuals who are
not perfect
you know
dr kieran armstrong she said
just like we don't want to judge
islam but the actions of some terrorists
we don't want to judge jesus but the
actions of some christian terrorists
yes
so i would like to invite our guest
to read the quran which is the source of
islam
that's how you can find out that what
islam stands for look into the noble
life of prophet muhammad peace be upon
him you'll be amazed to find out that
how he brought unity to humanity how he
eradicated racism how he eradicated
poverty how he uplifted women equal to
man in the eyes of god yes different
responsibilities but equality of reward
how he brought morality how he made a
society a sober society right no one was
drinking and no one was taking drugs
just imagine a society like that in our
time
so that is the beauty of islam that's
the guidance of islam and we invite you
to study islam
that is a
beautiful invitation and just to
repeat we're here not to support any
political party
but to give a clear
example of
through
the proper means
which is the quran and the example of
prophet muhammad what islam is
and what islam isn't
so now just really quickly for the
people out there who now they use this
as a pretext you know to want to still
invade a country or countries
and they say look well these are the
guys
you know because the countries are
invaded because of 911 and it's a
harboring
place for terrorists
so under this pretext this is why they
feel they should be there or they're
trying to just go ahead and use
inflammatory language to get people
riled up to kind of get some other
country over there get somebody over
there to get back to square one
there is a professor in the in the
chicago campus here
in the university of chicago
and he wrote a book called dying to win
he did a 25-year study on terrorism
and his main conclusion is that it's not
islam or the quran
or the muslim culture
that is making people extremist up there
it is the u.s occupation
as dr pape robert pape yes exactly
so non-muslim scholars were specialists
in this field they are saying that it is
our own doing that we are making
terrorists
you know they were some drone missile
operators they came on the news and they
said you know what
uh 95 90 actually of our drones they hit
the wrong target they're hitting women
and children and how homes and farmers
and parties
and people are dying
children and women and you know
so they said that you know we are
creating the terrorists
so the best thing that we can do is you
know quran says in chapter 5 verse
number 32 that
saving one life is like saving all of
humanity taking one life is taking the
life of all of humanity
islam says that every life is precious
may that be women and children and black
and white and and different religions
islam and uh i mean muslims and
christians all life is precious in islam
that means we as humans we have to be
equal
and just
when we deal with other people
there should not be any um you know you
and vetoes when it comes to israel for
example against the palestinians no all
life is equal in the eyes of the in in
in the eyes of god
so if we behave with that mindset
inshallah god willing there would be
justice in the world racism would be
eradicated uh women would be uplifted
they would not be objectified humanity
would be an ideal humanity with with
allah's mercy and guidance how just do
you think people would be with
themselves
and instead of getting into a state of
cognitive dissonance where now if the
truth was brought to them they
investigated it further and they saw
like close to 4 000 architects and
engineers and surveys have been done
where people are demanding a new
investigation and now if they look at
this study that was done an independent
study of three hundred thousand dollars
and they looked at all the evidence and
they saw that hold on that actually
islam we know islamic muslims had i mean
islam had clearly nothing to do in order
to encourage clean innocent men and
women and show this is just clear it's
lucidly clear but now when the whole new
slogan the slogan comes out never forget
but now when this really sinks in never
forget that islam
and like
david ray griffin who is a scholar in
this area he's actually a christian and
he says that all the evidence
paraphrasing what he says that somehow
linking
muslims to this act has been fabricated
so and this is not some conspiracy
theorist
these are this is an academic and many
academics you know structural engineers
and others are coming out and saying
that
really muslims had nothing to do with it
so this is would someone be sincere with
themselves to accept that truth because
this again was a catalyst so you got two
uh you have two things you can deal with
these people living in a cave
uh they just hate our way of life
they hate us you know what i mean so
they're going to come they don't even
have tvs
so they're coming all the way over here
you know to try to hurt us or this is a
big racket this is a big business and
that's the motivation behind 99
of these wars are you ready to accept
that truth what do you think and be just
with yourself yeah yeah we have to be
just and we cannot be gullible you know
do not blindly follow the media you know
media has their own agenda
they want to have more sponsors they
want to have more business so they want
to just uh show that news that is going
to bring the most viewers the news may
be true there may be small truth to it
but they will just you know spin uh the
truth so it's important for us a prime
example would be
invasion of iraq
with the pretext of weapons of mass
destruction and now we found out now
that uh
who was that uh prime minister of uk he
has to come on the tv he has to
apologize that you know what we made a
mistake weapons of mass destruction in
2003 when u.s invaded iraq with the
false pretext that's a beautiful example
that was a lie based on a clear lie one
million people who is going to come from
their families on their back now yes of
the us and the uk and the 54 allies who
supported them these muslims died and
look at the power of the media and all
these experts and everybody coming
together and they were able to come
together and orchestrate this this
invasion to come in and kill all these
people look at that ben shapiro if
you're listening this yeah i want you to
do a show on this how the u.s is at
fault and who was the presidents up
there right it was bush a conservative
president
his supporter that ben shapiro supports
him come on if you are truthful if you
are jew if you are a bible believer you
have to have the guts to come and say
u.s was wrong we need to compensate them
right every family should get millions
and millions of dollars from your tax
paying dollars because you supported a
war like that
humans islam
is just is equitable we have to make
sure
that we have to stand up for every
person
a you a christian a muslim an atheist
everyone
so we cannot just uh go and bomb people
and then say you know what we are sorry
no go and compensate them
so at the end of the day my dear friends
my dear viewers right brother eddie
this is not a show about geopolitics
this is a show about
we want to make sure that
our creator has created with a purpose
and
just as discussing about afghanistan in
the u.s and the war and all of that is
not enough we have to look at the higher
the greater purpose that our our creator
has given to us and that purpose is uh
that we should be worshiping the creator
we should be adjust to people good to
the neighbors good to parents you know
follow the laws the the wonderful laws
allah has given and allah has promised
in the quran chapter number two verse
number 25 if a person has the right
belief means not worshipping a human an
idol
an animal but worshipping only the
creator and doing good deeds the way our
allah
has mentioned in the quran and through
the example of muhammad peace be upon
him
right belief and doing good deeds allah
promises the people eternal paradise
so that's where you and me and all of us
we want to go so we need to make sure
that by following god's guidance as
present in the last testament
which came through muhammad peace be
upon him that is the way for our
salvation and i hope and pray that god
has mercy on us may god unite us may god
empower us uh may god help us to defeat
islamophobia anti-semitism xenophobia
racism anything out there and that is
possible when we wake up when we realize
there is a creator there is a last
testament the quran example of muhammad
peace be upon him and that's the way for
having the best in this world inshallah
god willing paradise in the hereafter a
lot to think about we got the message
hopefully get it to angelina jolie benny
shapiro and others out there the
conservative voices people out there we
got a lot in common and
other things that we can build on and i
hope that people can benefit from some
of this
some of the things that we've just
discussed thank you very much
welcome
and thank you guys for tuning in here to
the dean show
i helped get this message out
to
angelina jolie benny shapiro and we
invite them to come on the program so we
can have a nice discussion about these
things putting things from a different
perspective from the perspective really
sincerely trying to get the truth out
there especially if you're uneducated in
islam continue to tune in read the quran
for yourself
and check yourself where are you really
getting your information
and be sincere and do what
our guest was talking about
ask the creator alone for guidance and
he will facilitate away and be hungry
and have that earnest desire to really
want to know the truth because the truth
shall set you free we'll see you next
time here on the dean show subscribe if
you haven't already hit that
notification bell we'll see you next
time peace be with you assalamu alaikum